[Music]
tanner welcome to the ramsay show
hi guys how you guys doing doing great
helping ken and i help
good good i had a career question so i
have been in the medical marijuana
industry for about 11 years in a row now
as upper management i no longer want to
be in the career i want to do something
different you know i took your advice i
took a couple of your guys's courses
online i love them the proximity
principle i love it
i also downloaded your guys's resume
template
for the last two months i've been
sending out some resumes and
unfortunately i have not even received a
single phone call i was just wondering
if you guys can give me any advice
as to breaking the stigma of the
marijuana industry and how do i get in
to a different management role
okay well we got two different questions
there
i'm not i'm not sure i'm an expert on
breaking the stigma of medical marijuana
i mean honestly i i don't know
i because largely i'm not sure i know
what the stigma is i mean
it's not like some new concept all of a
sudden you know what i mean um uh but
i'll come back to that one i'm gonna
table that one for now and come back to
that let's let's talk about um
uh the second part of the question which
is how do i break through and start to
get some some some job interviews
um i i would stop just submitting
resumes unless and you may not have told
me everything but based on what you said
i'm assuming you're just sending out
resumes cold correct
yes yeah well that's like playing the
lottery okay um
especially in today's world
so even small businesses tanner are
using
you know uh artificial intelligent type
software so that resume submissions and
they've got keywords so they're looking
for based on the job description that
they've posted and your resume
forget the cannabis experience that you
have in the medical marijuana side of
things
they're looking for keywords that relate
to the job description it's like really
specific and if you enter in that
artificial intelligence and the software
that people are writing
really great and qualified candidates
sometimes will get kicked out just
because your resume doesn't have enough
of the keywords related to their job
description does that make sense i want
to make sure i don't talk too much
technical but does that underst you
understand what i'm saying
yes yes i do so the reality is is you
and i don't have any evidences right now
that somebody's looking at your resume
and seeing that you've been in medical
marijuana for 11 years and they're going
oh we're not calling that guy back we
don't really have any evidence of that
do we
no okay then so you're limiting yourself
by saying well that's why no that may
not be why at all
but let's also recognize that some
people
may have some sort of issue with it and
a stigma i mean that happens so how do
we remove both situations we're not
getting looked at because we're
submitting cold resumes and we have a
resume that's got a lot of experience on
it that may carry a stigma with it
here's how we eliminate both of those
two factors being limiting
we are focusing on relationships
connections connections connections
and you have got to submit a resume
you're still going to have to submit it
online just like you have been before
but only after
you've got somebody
who is vouching for you
who is submitting your resume personally
to somebody that they know this is how
you get
through the uh what i would call the
online pile right in the old days you
took in a physical resume and it may sit
on the hiring manager's desk now
everything is digital but to get noticed
you're going to have to have that
personal connection does that make sense
yes it does so when i you talked about
the proximity principle which is a book
i wrote a couple years ago also a
bestseller
and and you read that book yes
yes
well i hate to be so simplistic but you
got to go back in there and go okay wait
a second
what is it that i want to do fill in the
blank what is it that you're looking for
you've applied what kind of work you're
looking for
okay so i do know what i'm looking for
so
it is sending my resumes cold but
in my industry the thing that i really
the task i really love doing is supply
chain management and that's extremely
crucial to make sure we have all the
supplies and everything we need in our
facilities
after reading your book that's really
the only thing that drove me in our
industry so i would like to break away
from the cannabis industry and go to a
supply chain right or chain management
position so what so are you saying in
the phoenix arizona is that the big
circle we kind of draw a big circle on
the map and the greater phoenix area
that's where we want to look
uh yes okay great and there's plenty out
there there's of
so without saying any company names out
loud
um
you can think of the companies you've
applied to plus there's some other
companies that you're probably
interested in as well correct you got
them in your mind
yes all right so you have to think about
all the people you know
i mean you've been living in phoenix how
long
uh 23 years now all right just for a fun
exercise you ready
yes don't overthink this give me
ballpark numbers how many people
between close personal relationships
whether it be family friends
former co-workers close people then
acquaintances people that you know but
you don't do in life with them but if
you saw them on the street you said hi
they say hi to you so they're an
acquaintance uh and then even some
social media connections in the phoenix
area how many people you say that you
know
oh three or four thousand people three
or four thousand people all right how
many people do you think each one of
those people know
well probably two thousand at least as
well yeah i'm not good at math george
that's a lot of people well it gets
exponentially insane because those 2 000
people know another 2 000. now tanner i
backed i kind of backed you into this
because i want you to understand that
you know plenty of people you know
everybody you need to know to get the
job you know everybody you need to know
to make a connection to somebody in
these companies so the companies you've
applied to
that you didn't get any response at all
i want you to go back to the drawing
board plus all the new options and i
want you to start just playing this game
out i want you to talk to everybody that
you know get on social media and do it
email everybody that you know on
linkedin with a real email address not
the linkedin email address and say hey
i'm looking to get connected over this
company this company this company and
this company yeah do you know somebody
over there how well do you know him
would you be willing to introduce me to
him for a phone call a zoom or a coffee
tanner you starting to track with where
i'm going
yep yep and then here's what happens we
find the right connection and we get a
really strong recommendation before we
ever submit a resume maybe even a real
conversation with the hiring manager and
they go okay great and they know
something great about you they they have
a mutual connection where there's some
credibility that's how you're gonna go
about getting the gig and it doesn't
really matter i don't think that you're
that you've been in medical marijuana
you want to show your 11 years of
experience and how that supply chain
management logistics and everything you
did there makes you a great candidate
this is the hottest job market we've
ever seen and if nothing else i want you
to go to
ziprecruiter.com ken today
and upload your resume and let them go
to work for you as well george some
great advice there ken no i just wanted
to uh to add for tanner that the way i
got my job here as an intern attempt
started with a direct message on twitter
it did not start with my resume who was
that
that was to one of our personalities
yeah and i started working with them on
social media and i had a plan and i was
excited and i was persistent but not
aggressive and annoying and that turned
into a phone call with hr which turned
into another personality set that call
up yes and so that so what did the
credibility of that relationship mean to
the hr people why would they even do a
call with you
i have no idea there's a personal
connection because of the connection of
that personality who said hey george is
a not a nut
george is sharp i like george i think
it's worth a phone call yes that changed
everything and that was a twitter dm
that was free by the way yeah and so
tanner you got to get more creative and
there's a lot of ways to do this but
just sitting in the digital quagmire of
a resume pile not going to cut it use
that connections use those connections
that you have get creative show them
that you're really hungry to do this
kind of work i'm slow clapping right
here george because you just said
digital quagmire you like that i like it
because it's actually true this is what
the new world is like when you submit a
resume cold without a relationship you
are essentially putting yourself in the
digital quagmire yes
i'm you know to impress ken coleman with
a word that's a big day because you've
got a lot of 10 words
it's amazing